the Joe Rogan experience yeah I mean I
wrote a book about Operation Paperclip
and oh my god talk about a rabbit's hole
that's a rabbit hole they're having
let's explain to people that don't know
what we're talking about Operation
Paperclip was when after World War two
the United States gathered up a ton of
scientists from Nazi Germany brought
them over to America and even Wernher
von Braun they had Wernher von Braun run
NASA he was a Nazi like a hundred
percent Nazi good friends with Hitler
type not say yes he was he ran a Berlin
rocket factory where they hung the five
slowest Jews they would hang them out
front so everybody would know like this
is what happens when you work slow well
hang you I mean the Simon Wiesenthal
Center said that if Wernher von Braun
was alive today they would prosecute him
for crimes against humanity
yes and that was the head announcer that
was the head of NASA that was the guy
who got us to the moon that was the big
cheese guy yeah so we were willing to
put a lot of really dark things aside in
order to gather out the best scientists
of the Soviet Union couldn't get them
all and they got a few of them as well
but we got how many more than a thousand
right allegedly 1,400 but I would not be
surprised if you know the story changes
and there were more right no but that
goes back to our discussion earlier
about being in pole position I mean
that's why we grabbed those Nazis we
were like if we don't get them the
Russians I get it I get it
and you know and I'm sure the Nazis
could say I didn't want to do it they
made me I'm a nice person I love Jews
you know oh that was part of the
mythology it was like we got the good
Germans well right we didn't we got the
we got the top Germans and who do you
think the top Germans were yeah they
were coveted by Hitler Himmler Goering
you know yeah I mean these guys were
right I mean there were guys that we
grabbed out of the docks at Nuremberg
literally to come be part of our program
you know one of these get smart you're
an asset right I mean that's what
ginga's Cohn used to do he'd take
warlords from the other side and capture
I'm gonna go listen come on for me I'm
mad I mean what you
ideology aside I'm super smart and I
want that to be known that's good that's
that's the competitor right I mean you
can't you cannot be the best rocket
designer in the world and not want those
talents you know demonstrated that's
Wernher von Braun story that's the story
of all of them and that was was so
shocking writing that book because it's
a it's like wow you know huge amounts of
talent but how far will the competitor
go to see their baby come to fruition
what are they willing to put aside yeah
did you pay any attention to the other
places where Nazis went when they
escaped Germany like Argentina in
particular you ever seen any of that
stuff they have entire German towns down
in Argentina right they do
Oktoberfest down there they wear
lederhosen they drink out of Stein's
it's crazy they speak German and you're
like what the [ __ ] is this like my
friend Tim Kennedy went down there and
he said he was literally talking to
people interviewing people and they had
photos of SS soldiers on their wall and
they would talk about how grandfather
was a hero and like like you are you're
the descendants of escaped Nazis and
they put together a town down there I
mean the way the Nazis were able to flee
is
I can't read enough of that I mean
that's what Jamie now we're talking
about it's they are oh my god and it
it's endless I mean they're so you know
the ones that we there was a famous guy
that we got he was the Surgeon General
of the Third Reich I mean think about
that okay dr. Walter Schreiber
I mean he was such a bad dude he was in
charge of the vaccine program I mean you
just put those words together and your
mind goes really dark right but we
wanted him because he was an expert in
vaccines and we brought him to the
United States he was the only Nazi I
found of the ones the paperclip
scientists who came here that that was
actually outed right he was outed as a
Nazi and that's because one of the
investigators at the Nuremberg trials
recognized him oh Jesus
and we he's the only one we got out of
here and guess where he went
she lived out the rest of his life there
the the show was called finding Hitler
there they were trying to find evidence
that Hitler somehow escaped there's
really a [ __ ] premise to the show
but what was interesting is that there
were thousands and thousands of Nazis
that made it to Argentina and set up
shop throughout South America it's a lot
of Germans down there it's kind of weird
if you can imagine me on book tour of
like the kind of questions I get because
we're talking right having written books
about area 51 Nazis to make assassin
soul people I mean just last night oh is
that a book giving you the signing and
people are like is Hitler really dead
you know Karthi i mean that if he was
alive he'd be the oldest man alive right
imagine he was probably like how old was
he during World War two he had to be in
this 14b hundreds you know I mean but
right or they say he cloned himself yeah
heard 60 years old 120 now Jamie knows
that's an old man I mean there's been a
hundred 20 year old people but it's
[ __ ] pretty rare yeah so Operation
Paperclip was not even publicly
acknowledged until what was it like the
90s like when did they when did it
become public thing was through the
Freedom of Information Act
wasn't it was a very intrepid journalist
named Linda hunt Hill shot out the
window yeah I mean she but you know she
broke the story that's what's amazing I
mean as a journalist you're always
writing on the shoulders of those before
you right mm-hmm and she had it really
hard because she did a Freedom of
Information Act request got all these
documents that no one had ever seen and
then the government sent her a bill for
a hundred and twenty five thousand
dollars and she had to spend a lot of
time this is what I understand I never
interviewed her but for for xeroxing
fees what yeah I just love that detail
because it's like it's such a covert way
of getting someone to stop it's like
okay here's the information we had to
give it to you but now here's your bill
imagine if the government's coming down
on you for 125 grand
yeah see Galica me want to call a bunch
of rich people and go hey let's all just
donate a thousand dollars and it's a
different world now you could do that
you could do a GoFundMe campaign you
know my god in the 80s and the 90s you
were just like out on a limb yeah they
would crush you financially we actually
had this very same discussion yesterday
with my friend Phil DeMars is being sued
by Marineland and because of he was a
walrus trainer and trained orcas and
he's showing how horrific it wasn't
black fish that's SeaWorld but that's
SeaWorld is actually the way he says
it's a day in the park compared to
marine land marine lance a horrific
place in capital and anyway they have
been trying to squash him with legal
beats by dragging out his legal fees by
dragging on his case but he set up
GoFundMe and all his legal bills get
paid for from people that want him to
win the good fight and this is a this is
an option today that wasn't available to
Linda when she was exposing this $25,000
do you [ __ ] like she should sue them
for misappropriation of funds like does
it cost you really $125,000 to print
those things out of it does you guys
should be in jail like that's like with
like those $10,000 hammers that they
have and mm-hmm the Pentagon yeah yeah
so she gets all this information and
does the government immediately
acknowledge that the important Nazis
that no I mean she wrote the first book
and it was just stunning and and you
know it was us late 80s Early 90s okay
and you know then more gets revealed
because they gave her a certain amount I
mean I filed a bunch of FOIA as there
was releases I went to Germany for you
meaning freedom Freedom of Information
Act yes then I went to Germany and
looked in their archives with like a
fellow a German PhD who had you know
real access to stuff and was able to
translate for me while we were there
looking at this stuff I interviewed a
lot of grandchildren of Nazis and
children of Nazis and you know I mean
this one extraordinary oh my god there's
a guy I told you about Shriver
I'm on the narrative level humans acting
I'm so interested in rivalry in
competition right as a concept because
this is what America does to be the best
and also as humans right because people
like that they're built like that so the
Nazis had rivals amongst themselves and
Schreiber's rival was dr. Bluhm who was
in charge of the biological weapons
program for Hitler okay and Blum had a
son and Blum was prosecuted at Nuremberg
you can see a picture of him with a big
Dueling scar you know he was a bad dude
he was a Dueling scar Dueling scar dual
like a sword sword fighting it was like
among the Nazis they would they would
duel with one another when they were
younger students and then they would
pack the wound with horsehair to make it
even more pronounced because it looked
ferocious pull up Jamie pull up well you
can pull up dr. Bluhm bol em ii but also
right and also you can pull if you pull
up Kurt Debus who was the director of
our JFK Center he was part he was NASA's
Vaughan Browns number two he had a huge
Dueling scar and yet when you know II
look at there he is right there
knowing what we know now it's like come
on you're trying to tell me that guy's
not a hardcore Nazi so those guys had
dueling scars on their face yeah you see
him how often did they do well when they
were in college of death no no no no no
it was like on guard you know and then
they would I'm saying venting fencing oh
this guy had it too yeah how'd they not
get poked in the eyes oh I guess that
was the gentlemen's rule how do you [ __ ]
listen you go in for the cheek you hit
the eye like that happens all the time I
mean it must have cut a lot of eyeballs
out I haven't seen any photographs of
missing eyeballs but there's a lot right
on the cheek so maybe that was the whole
point it was actually just a bit for
show oh I am a weird butt but it was a
revoir it was a badge of honor yeah
there's more and and but so they all had
on their face it's on the same spot
doing scars yeah
Wow so imagine I wanted to have these
scars that was a Jesus Christ oh they
had goggles on oh there you go that's
how they didn't take up academic fencing
it says academic fencing so what they
were essentially doing they were having
fencing matches with real swords not
with ones with tips Wow and cut in their
faces up [ __ ] man oh Jesus look at this
guy's face
yikes Wow
doing cults cults that is crazy
so when you consider like wow that
people people did not know about that
and then you've got these Germans
walking around America as part of our
space program in our science programs
and oh these are the good Germans I mean
now you really have to say to yourself
come on Nazis yeah it's cars in their
face absolutely oh that's dark matter
gee Fight Club Yeah right off I super og
yeah that's crazy Wow so I go to
interview um doc sometimes you as a
journalist you can get amazing
information from these guys oh my god
they're sliced up after European martial
arts yeah well I mean that is a martial
art means an art of war really a sword
fighting is a martial art I mean many
martial arts have weapons yes sorry you
could say you go to interviews people so
to piece together the story right I
can't tell you others can write some
time in the to find out more about the
Nazis I went to Germany and sought out
some children of these top top Nazis to
see if maybe they didn't have journals
or anything they might share with me and
one of them was dr. Bluhm his son I
tracked down I found him and he said yes
you may come visit me and it was such a
remarkable journey it was like he lived
in the Black Forest I'd take like a taxi
through the mountains up over the hill
down through the valley you know into a
courtyard behind a church - dr. Blom's
house so he was the junior
to his father who was this horrific Nazi
I mean a top Nazi had favor of the fear
were what was called the golden party
badge right Hitler gave out these little
buttons Blum's was I believe number six
so that's how favored he was and his son
dr. Kurt Blome whereas the father was in
charge of the biological weapons program
so his plan was to you know murder
people with biological weapons from
nature right the son had been a medical
doctor but had left the profession to
cure people with flowers
it's called Bach flower therapy so he
was this very interesting individual who
had never given an interview before and
he agreed to let me come to him so I go
on that journey I go to his house and he
was remarkable I mean he was so
interesting talk about the sins of the
father you know I mean my god what he
what he had what he had as a burden
right and he and I asked him to tell me
everything he could about his father and
he did and then he asked me to tell me
what I knew about his father I had
information from the German archives
about his father that he did not have
talked like that his father had given
something I'd just come from this
archive and found these documents dr.
Bluhm ordered that 6,000 tuberculin even
sonder be handling that's the German
word what does that mean special
treatment there's a euphemism for you
that was kill those 6,000 tubercular
Jews what do you say tubercular is that
people with tuberculosis they were
suffering from tuberculosis and he dr.
Bluhm worked closely with Himmler and
they just decided to kill him and you
know sitting there talking to this man
telling him about his father at his
request was remarkable and then he's
telling me what he knows and then as I'm
getting ready to leave he says to me I'd
like you to have these and he takes down
from his incredible bookshelf
he himself had written eight books right
and he takes down these books and he
hands them to me and they're in these
wrappers and I can see that they have
Nuremberg
nomenclature on them and what they are
is they're his father's documents from
his Nuremberg trial and he and I'm like
I can't take these I'm I thought he
meant take them back to my hotel room
look at them and then you know bring
them back the next morning when we were
doing the next interview and he said no
no I want you to have them
and I was like I can't have them and he
said I don't want them and you should
have them and it gave them to me so I
had this stack so I was like on my trip
home it was so perplexing because I
threw out all of my clothes I was like
screw the clothes I mean I just carry
travel with the carry-on bag right so I
in my carry-on bag all I have is this
Nazi paraphernalia that is dr. Blum's oh
my the deputy Surgeon General of the
Third Reich's documents from Nuremberg
covered with swastikas all more I mean
he was acquitted at Nuremberg based on
all these documents okay and that by the
way based on human experiments and I'm
at the airport and I realized suddenly
oh my god swastikas like this is illegal
if they go through my bag I'm going to
be arrested I'm carrying I mean I'm
carrying these incendiary do you have
any copies of your book on you oh yeah
no no no I was just like at least one
Joe I was sweating almost as hard as I
was sweating at the beginning of this
interview right I think I went because
you know I was like wow I went through
no problem got home I have them my
office no luck you didn't go through
Israel well you know what it's not the
swastika is not out there but it is in
Germany you may not have any Nazi
paraphernalia whatsoever in fact my
paperclip book which has a swastika on
it had to be redesigned the cover for
the German publication and it just has
like broken up images of the Nazis
because you cannot reproduce that image
in German it's I mean I'm not Pro
swastika
but it's so strange that we've given so
much power to this design that you can't
even see it it used to be there's a
there's a temp
out here that I think is I believe it's
a Hindu temple and it was a part of
Hinduism that this swastika predates
World War two it predates the Nazis
predates their they're sort of
reclaiming of it and the this building
that was built out here in the nineteen
I think was built in the 1920s has
swastikas on there's a big plaque
explaining why there's swastikas on it I
know they had a different angle mm-hmm
but I mean talk about branding right I
mean my god that was and the Nazis were
you know kings of that I mean they were
only that the mustache that guy killed
that mustache
there's not another thing like that but
he didn't kill the dueling scar right
that could come back do you think no no
no not after your show what do you have
four million viewers probably people
don't think about it that way they don't
think about the dueling scars being a
Nazi thing no no that's what I find a
remarkable right
they really don't but the Nazis did the
Nazis did and then you look there's an
amazing photograph of JFK Lyndon Johnson
Kurt Davis sitting at you know for a
launch a moon launch and there's Davis
with his huge Dueling scar and I'm like
and their position was oh he's one of
the good Germans
well that culture was a culture of
ruthlessness I mean it was a even the
good ones there he is
yes good job Jamie look at that can you
believe star on his face
they still give out an award by the way
that's called the Kurt Debus award and I
rang them up and said like why are you
guys giving out this award he was a
hardcore Nazi well they say they were
like they've hemmed and hawed and I
finally said well at least tell me what
you say to people who asked that
question you know they said well no
one's ever asked us that question before
Annie well they will now it's when you
really stop and think about the horrific
nature of what the Nazis did I mean how
inhuman it was how how crazy it was like
that had to permeate the entire
culture there is no good Nazis there was
not one even one of them that was looped
into that had to be responsible for some
awful awful [ __ ]
I mean Einstein said it the best when he
said you should you know you could have
left like people who could have left
should have left all right well do you
know the story Fritz Harbor right the
guy yes I mean he wound up having to
flee and he's the guy who created Zyklon
gasps he's you know he created his icon
a which had smell built into it so that
would warn you when you were using this
pesticide and then the Nazis turned it
into zyklon-b
or they removed that element that added
the smell and just this odorless
horrific poisonous gas that they used to
gas the Jews and he was a Jew I mean I
you know then when you think about he
became he was no longer useful to them
because they figured out he really was a
Jew yeah well one since world war two
came around see he was a part of World
War one when they first started using
gas and he was there's a great radio lab
podcast about it I think it's called
the bad show but anyway what essentially
says that he was winning he was up for
the Nobel Prize at the same time he was
wanted for crimes against humanity
because he was up for the Nobel Prize
for creating the Habra method of
extracting nitrogen from the atmosphere
which was used for fertilizer which to
this day they say 50% of the nitrogen in
human bodies was created by the harbor
method so what you get from food from
vegetables like that nitrogen 50% of it
at least is coming from this guy's
method who was a scientist who was a Jew
who was working in Germany before it
became Nazi Germany and then was the guy
who figured out how to use gas on people
it's that dark his story this dead dog
story I mean he died looking for medical
treatment because he had a flee Germany
and he's had a bad heart he died on a
road trying to get to Switzerland that's
the thing what's what's falling yeah
yeah it's I mean Nazi Germany is like
the pole position taken way too far and
that's what's remarkable that the
Pentagon was like okay but we can learn
from
mmm-hmm and there there are elements
that are dark in that well it also comes
out of the devastation of World War one
right the economic devastation the
defeat the Germans are in this terrible
state overall in terms of their morale
and then along comes this charismatic
psychopath that is just really good at
screaming to this day I don't speak
German but this day when you watch that
guy scream and yell at all those people
and see them respond it gives you chills
like that kind of charisma that kind of
influence that someone has where they
can do that in front of thousands and
thousands of people and everyone's
goose-stepping and so to see we're very
fortunate there's not something like
that right now and our forefathers and
our grandparents and whoever fought in
world war ii if it wasn't for them who
knows where this world would be right
now because that was a literal evil
empire straight out of Star Wars I mean
that was like the Sith Lord they were
they really were there were human beings
who were doing some of the most evil
[ __ ] that you could it almost demonic if
you really stopped and thought about it
if there were demons pretended to be
people they would do the same thing I
mean it that's why I think it's a rabbit
hole because it's so hard to comprehend
that like a culture of educated
individuals in that moment in time that
you talked about between World War two
World War one and World War two could
could completely become Minette
malevolent yeah that's one of the more
disturbing things about the Nazis was
that there were so many of these people
that they did extract through Operation
Paperclip brilliant engineers and
scientists that were also evil like
those two things are very uncomfortable
for us we like to think of our
scientists as being the people that are
out there trying to solve the mysteries
of the universe and provide us with the
technology to make our life better here
on earth not the Nazis they were trying
to figure out how to kill people better
they were trying to figure out how to
use rockets to shoot them at Europe and
blow people up and it is a it's one of
the more telling and horrific times in
our history when you because it's it's
one of
one of the more horrific ones that we
have footage of because we don't have
footage of Genghis Khan we don't have
footage of Alexander the Great
we don't we have stories and tales of
Napoleon and some photographs and
drawings of dictators past and prep but
we have a lot of footage from Vietnam we
have a lot of footage from World War two
we have a lot of footage from modern
wars and out of all of them the one that
scares us the most and scares me the
most is World War two do you think those
scientists when they came here because
this is a this is a I could not figure
this out even after writing that whole
book is it do you think they came here
and actually thought about what they had
done or they were able to convince
themselves that they were the good
Germans that they were part of it
because I never saw a single bit of
remorse ever like no one ever
acknowledged what they had done so it
made me wonder
I guess results very right I mean I
think there's probably two people that
go through the same thing and one person
has no problem with it and the other
person literally can't sleep I don't
know it's a good question it would be
interesting to interview them the the
ones who've been caught who've been
prosecuted and had been chased down and
they've got one fairly recently they
caught a Nazi like just a few months ago
it's one of the last ones using as 90s I
believe the ones who survived they all
tell different stories and some of them
say they just wished following orders
and you know some of them say that they
didn't do it they're being framed they
all have different stories it's it's one
of them you know you write a book about
that and or you think about it and you
kind of have you go down the rabbit hole
and then you have to you have to ask
yourself what does this mean or you kind
of it's too dark right and so I asked
that question to a a schvitz survivor
okay who I wrote about in the book his
name was Gerhard Murkowski and he the
reason he was he survived Auschwitz was
because he was taken over to the labor
camp
which was called buna so it was a rubber
factory and it was led by this truly
evil man named otto Ambrose who became
part of Operation Paperclip okay after
being tried at Nuremberg and being
convicted of mass murder and genocide
right we got him out and he worked for
us you got to read the story I mean it's
just it's just astonishing Otto Ambrose
extreme chemist
oh my right but he was so he so gerhard
was at buna this factory this rubber
factory and he lived and I did an
interview with him because I was asking
him you know the flip side of of all of
that and his whole family was killed at
Auschwitz and I said to him what does
any of you know we went through all
these questions to try to get some
closure to this or some meaning and I
said and then I'll we land and I said
well you know we couldn't have we
couldn't answer what does this mean
right what does it mean for today
couldn't answer
yeah so when I asked him what matters
about all this he went like this he
lifted up his sleeve and he showed me
his tattoo and he said that matters and
I have that image seared in my mind I
had never seen a tattoo from Auschwitz
before and I have not since and it also
made me think cuz I thought he's gonna
die soon and he has diet sense and then
that tattoos gone
so all you have is the exchange of
information and people talking about it
yeah the eyewitnesses died how did they
get that guy out of Nuremberg how did
they get them to release him well okay
so he was convicted at Nuremberg then he
went to prison he went to the prison
where we had all the didn't execute him
no obviously they executed like the top
Nazis and then a lot of these guys went
to prison so there was a bunch of trials
and so I went to the prison I saw his
cell I mean in Germany was intense
Landsberg prison and then we because we
were sort of policing Nazi Germany after
it was not you know after the war was
over were police in Germany
and then Kate and a guy named McCoy was
in charge he was kind of like the
Governor General of Germany and the
Germans wanted Germany back and they
were like we're tired of you guys
policing us the threat from the Russians
was very real and so deals were made I
mean I write about all this in paperclip
you know based on the documents and one
of the provisions was we want our guys
out of prison we want them back in
society and that was arranged and again
you don't even know these things you
know they're like but that was and then
Otto amperes and they even gave him his
money back that was astonishing and the
family still has this villa in
Switzerland I believe or maybe it's the
Bavarian Alps that had been in the
family which is money from you know from
world from Nazi Germany and I called up
the son to interview him he was not as
forthright as dr. Bluhm son and you know
he hung up on me and said if you if you
ever contact me again all you know they
have very serious privacy laws in
Germany I thought about going and
knocking on his front door my lawyer was
like Annie do not do that they have very
different laws in Germany for privacy
yes even if issues like this son of a
Nazi yes absolutely well I would imagine
look if he didn't do anything he
shouldn't be responsible for what his
father did no but he has the villa that
was the point I had all the money right
and he got that money from his father
who got that money from stealing it from
people else during World War two yeah
like what happens there yes but if you
go back to that like we should really
find out who had the plantations in
America and who benefited from that like
go several generations from there I mean
you could get weird with with war
reparations deeds where people profited
yeah I mean which is sometimes a reason
why you I realized in looking at these
in reporting these books which is why
certain things are kept secret I mean
they open up a whole can of worms about
reparations sure you know yeah Wow was
operating Operation Paperclip writing
that book was that
one of the most disturbing ones reason I
mean that was so dark my husband is
amazing he's Norwegian right and the nor
the Norway was occupied by the Nazis for
five years like people kind of forget
that but he he grew up there and his mom
you know was a grade schooler and was
really impacted like didn't go to school
for five years while the Nazis were
there they were gonna breed with the
Norwegians cuz they were such lovely
Aryan people so my husband having a
Norwegian mom was like when I was
writing paperclip it would be so dark
sometimes I would be like down in my
office like I can't you know honey I
kick you know uh and he'd be down there
with a sandwich or coffee and say but
are you throwing another Nazi under the
bus and I would say yes and he'd say
keep typing right and then I realized
well wait a minute the neutral
journalist has to really make sure that
she's not just throwing Nazis under the
bus without really good reason and so
when I was in Germany at the archives I
went to Dachau the concentration camp
and I asked the lead archivist if I
could come and see the worst possible
photographs that no one wants to see and
he said absolutely and I didn't write
about them in the book because I didn't
want to subject people to that kind of
horror but I looked at them and I
watched I saw with my own eyes people
moments before they were killed
you know and then the bodies afterwards
and these are inhuman experiments to you
know to see whether or not pilots could
survive height or you know they
simulated different things in chambers a
high altitude or speed and I saw I saw
photographs of you know freezing people
to death right because they were trying
to develop programs where they would
they wanted to see at what temperature
humans actually died right and so they
experimented on Jews these are these are
some of the doctors that came on our
programs and I looked at those that
evidence and I was that blew me away and
then I knew when I left there okay I can
I can throw these Nazis under the bus it
is it's such a crazy time in history
well you really stop and think about all
the different experiments that they did
do it's almost like they just opened up
the vault of evil and said listen we
have an opportunity these P
our people let's do whatever we want
it's like they're fake people it's like
like they were an invention I mean the
perception really played into it oh so
gross it's so scary to think about that
humans just you know a generation or two
away they're capable of doing that
[Applause]